nous passons à l'article 37 et j'ai deux
demandes de parole sur article monsieur
Chassin je vous en prie chers collègu
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues le rapport Libau sur le
grand âge en 2019 recommandait la fusion
des sections soins dépendan et ce
rapport préconiserit la 5e rangeche de
l'Assurance Maladie pour la prise en
charge de la dépendance
prise en charge par la nation cette
réforme permettait de positionner un
financeur unique soin indépendance qui
faciliterit le pilotage et la gestion en
2023 un rapport remis par la à la
première ministre par la députée madame
pierrez bon reprenez cette
recommandation sans remboursement du
ticket modérateur par le conseil général
car il faut laisser au Département des
marges de manœuvre pour le le
domiciliaire avec le SAD et le SIAD et
une gestion départementale avec une
équité dans tous les cantons et bien sûr
il y a aussi le le RSA cette proposition
faite dans cette article 37 est une
régression car c'est simplement une
expérimentation pour les départements
qui le souhaitent avec un remboursement
d'ailleurs dont on ne connaît pas les
calculs alors je pense que c'est une
erreur effectivement de de repartir de
cette logique dynamique de la prise en
charge du grand âge et de ne pas
financer comablement la dépendance car
nous voulons doubler les personnes de de
85 ans entre 2020 et 2040 en passant de
1004 dépendance à 2 millions donc un DOM
un virage domiciliaire oui organisé par
le Conseil départemental et en épad les
personnes dépendantes qui ne pourront
pas rester à domicile avec une section
hébergement et une section soins
déépendant c'est bien sûr cet
organisation qui est plébiscitée par les
responsables des épades à plus de 80 %
et nonont pas le choix
des départements qui V entraîner des
distorsions par et donc une régression
donc je rappelle malgré tout les
proposition du Président de la
République 50000 emplois en 2027 qui
doivent absolument être mis en place 2
millions par an pour prendre en charge
de façon décente nos aîné si chers
collègues j'avais une demande de parole
sur article de Madame
Ferré merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre donc nous évoquons
maintenant cet article 37 qui s'inscrit
dans le chapitre portant sur le titre
renforcer la politique de soutien à
l'autonomie l'occasion pour moi est
donnée de rappeler la situation euh
extrêmement grave dans laquelle se
trouve 80 % de nos épades nous l'avons
évoqué au début de l'examen de ce PLFSS
rappeler que les moyens ne sont pas là
rappelez que beaucoup de ces
établissements sont en très grande
difficulté sont inquiets même pour leur
avenir pour poursuivre leur activité et
maintenir cet accueil dans les
meilleures conditions non seulement des
personnes âgées mais aussi permettre au
personnel de travailler dans les
meilleures conditions donc je souhaitais
faire ce ce rappel vous alerter puisque
je n'avais pas eu l'occasion on va dire
de de m'adresser à vous particulièrement
mais que vous sachiez aussi je ne doute
pas que vous ayez connaissance de la
situation mais sachez que dans nos
territoires partout dans nos nos
territoires partout dans nos
départements euh c'est un véritable cri
d'alarme un cri d'alerte pour avoir des
moyens supplémentaires pour répondre à
cette à ce défi on pourrait dire qui est
devant nous qui est celui de la prise en
charge des personnes
âgées madame Ferré madame leou pour une
parole sur
article merci madame la Présidente à
l'occasion de cette article 37 comme mes
collègues je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur l'impérieuse nécessité d'
aboutir sur un projet de loi grand âge
et autonomie nous sommes inquiets face à
l'immensité des défis auquels nous
sommes confrontés avec les conséquences
que l'on sait sur les établissements
d'accueil des personnes âgées notamment
publes c'est-à-dire les collectivités
territoriales qui on sont les les
gestionnaires les soignants les
soignants n'en peuvent plus les
gestionnaires n'en peuvent plus en
Bretagne des élus se sont organisés pour
nous alerter vous alerter madame la
ministre en créant un collectif des
crédits supplémentaires ont été inscrit
pour tenter de colmater les déficits je
ne sais s'ils suffiront mais ce dont je
suis sûr c'est que ces crédits ne
répondront que ponctuellement aux
difficultés financières des
établissements qui ne peuvent plus payer
leur facture d'énergie leur charge de
personnel mais le problème est
structurel quel reste à charge pour les
familles quelle contribution pour les
collectivités de nombreuses réflexions
quant aux modèle de financement des épad
ont été menés le modèle actuel est à
bout de soufle le temps de l'action est
là et est attendu de nombreux rapports
existent y compris sur le reste à charge
madame piresbon a fait des
recommandations sur le financement mais
votre proposition d'expérimentation pour
les départements volontaires de
transférer le volet dépendance à l'État
ne peut pas être dissocié d'un plan
global de prise en charge de nos années
merci merci chers collègues je vais donc
maintenant passer à l'examen des
amendements et je vais commencer par le
517 rectifié présenté par Monsieur
merci madame la Présidente le présent
amendement corédigé avec ma collègue
Monique Lubin propose de supprimer
l'article 37 en effet l'article met en
place une simplification du mode de
financement des EPAD et USLD en
fusionnant à partir de 2025 dans les
départements volontaires les dépenses
afférentes à la prise en charge de la
dépendance et celle afférente en soi en
les regroupant dans une section unique
relevant d'un financement pour la 5e
branche de la sécurité sociale la CN sa
via les ARS cette
expérimentation se distingue par son
caractère irréversible pour les
départements qui s'y engage ce qui est
un premier problème mais elle induit
également pour les départements une
modification de la gouvernance de la
politique locale de la dépendance et de
l'autonomie tel qu'elle est susceptible
de rendre impossible toute action
volontariste innovante et d'ampleur en
la matière de la part de ses
collectivités dont c'est aujourd'hui la
compétence cette modification mais
également en péril l'existant c'est
pourquoi le présent amendement propose
la suppression de
l'article beaucoup cher collègue je vais
demander à la rapporteur son avis pour
la commission s'il vous plaît merci
madame la Présidente la répartition du
financement des épades entre les
sections soins et dépendance est une
source de complexité et de coût qui
apparaissent de moins en moins justifié
en effet cette répartition perd de sa
pertinence compte tenu de l'évolution du
profil des résidents de plus en plus
dépendant par ailleurs ce modèle de
financement entraîne des coûts de
gestion importants pour les
établissements les variations du forfit
dépendance d'un département à l'autre
peuvent engendrer des inégalités
territoriales enfin le coût induit pour
les département s'avèrent également
élevé au regard de leur marge de
décision spécifique la grande majorité
des établissements soulligne la
nécessité d'une réforme et considère
qu'avoir affaire à un financeur unique
est une priorité or il semble plus
cohérent que ce financeur soit la
branche autonomie et que le pilote soit
la RS le département conserverait
néanmoins un rôle important à l'égard
des éepad outre ses compétences
d'autorisation des établissements et
d'aide social à l'hébergement il aurait
notamment un rôle de coordination la
commission est donc favorable à
l'engagement d'une réforme structurelle
en ce sens en revanche comme vous le
soullignez le dispositif proposé et
problématique car il institue une mesure
pérenne à la carte je vous présenterai
un amendement dans quelques instants qui
tend à passer à une véritable
expérimentation avant d'envisager la
généralisation du dispositif c'est donc
un avis
défavorable merci avis de madame la
ministre sur cet
amendement merci avant de m'exprimer sur
l'amendement je tenais à dire que le le
gouvernement est bien conscient des
problématiques auxquelles sont
confrontés de de nombreux établissements
il y a encore peu peu de temps j'étais
aussi parlementaire sur le terrain j'ai
aussi vu au combien effectivement les
professionnels et je tiens d'ailleurs à
rendre un hommage vibrant au
professionnels qui travaillent dans ces
établissements pour accompagner les
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
et notamment nos anciens et donc il y a
effectivement beaucoup beaucoup à faire
pour j'allais dire relever
les défis et d'autant plus que nous
sommes
effectivement on fait face à un choc
démographique important donc d'où la
nécessité effectivement d'avancer sur le
sujet alors pour ce qui est de cet
amendement qui vise donc à la supprimer
certains article à supprimé donc le
régime adapté de financement des épades
proposé donc dans le cadre de ce
pfss je tiens à dire quand même c'est
une réforme qui est attendue et voulue
par de nombreux de nombreux acteurs du
fait du bon sens aussi en effet la
frontière et cela a été dit par Madame
la rapporteur la frontière entre le soin
et la dépendance tend à s'estomper le
niveau de dépendance des résidents d'pad
n'a fait que croître ce qui peut
justifier euh effectivement une prise en
charge par la branche autonomie de la
sécurité euh sociale d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on constate hein euh sur de
nombreuses dépenses qui relèvent de la
section dépendance et qui sont en fait
euh déjà couvertes en toute ou partie
par la branche euh autonomie comme par
exemple les postes d'aide soignant ou de
certaines revalorisations salariales de
plus le système actuel est par ailleurs
source et cela a été dit également de
complexité qui pour les départements
entre autres et je salue bien sûr
également le travail qui est mené par
les départements puisque c'est quand
même aussi j'allais dire ça relève de
leur compéten régaliennees que
d'accompagner le grand âge et
effectivement ces départements sont
amenés à calculer la location
personnalisée d'autonomie en
établissement qui est source bien sûr de
de difficultés avec une complexité de
gestion et de facturation pour les ESPAD
enfin euh nous avons euh choisi dès le
départ de mener toutefois cette r
réforme sur la base du volontariat et
j'insiste là-dessus sur la base du
volontariat des départements c'est aussi
demandé par les départements il faut le
dire certaines collectivités territorial
le demande il s'agit uniquement de
donner plus de choix de gestion donc
d'une certaine façon de respecter la
liberté des uns et des autres je ne
voudrais pas en tous les cas laisser
penser à une
recentralisation des politiques de
l'autonomie je le dis et j'insiste
là-dessus les départements doivent
rester chef de fil des politiques de
l'autonomie qui bien au-delà de la
gestion des épades comprennent aussi le
virage domiciliaire qui est déjà engagé
maintenant depuis quelques années où
nous avons besoin de solutions tout à
fait innovantes mais aussi bien sûr vous
savez que c'est beaucoup plus complexe
est beaucoup plus large que ça ça touche
à l'immobilier ça touche au transport
j'entends néanmoins votre inquiétude sur
le caractère irréversible ça a été
souligné aussi nous pourrons réaliser la
transformation de la fusion des sections
en une expérimentation plus encadré afin
de disposer d'une évaluation solide et
de rassurer les départements qui sont
prêts à franchir le pas donc pour toutes
ces raisons je suis défavorable à
l'amendement de suppression merci Madame
la Ministre j'ai une demande de par
parole de Madame Lubin pour explication
de vote je vous en prie oui merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre moi par
essence maintenant je me méfie de toutes
les réformes qui sont faites en avec
comme argumentation la simplification et
le bon
sens parce que souvent quand on parle de
bon
sens ça veut dire que la réflexion est
plutôt assez courte excusez-moi et quand
on parle de simplification on voit bien
à quoi ça à quoi ça amène quand chaque
fois qu'on a fait des réformes avec pour
mîre mot la simplification on a toujours
fini par complexifier les choses comme
d'autres ici collègues moi je suis
toujours élu départemental les
établissements ne viennent pas de me
parler de la complexité de la gestion
pour la en ce qui concerne la
facturation entre les départements et
les ARS ils viennent me parler de leur
manque de moyens et excusez-moi du peu
mais quand on me parle de
recentralisation vers l'état à un moment
et on le voit dans ce PLFSS où le slogan
phare c'est faire des économies sans
donner ABSOLUMENT jamais aucun moyen
supplémentaire et refuser
systématiquement toutes les pistes de de
recettes supplémentaires que nous
proposons je ne suis pas encline à faire
confiance à une recentralisation vers
l'état vraiment pas et dans un certain
nombre de départ ement parce que cet
amendement c'est un certain nombre de
départements qui le demande aussi dans
un certain nombre de départements
novateurs qui n'ont pas attendu et
heureusement d'ailleurs que l'État
produise sa grande réforme et sa grande
politique en faveur des personnes âgées
dans ces départementsl qui mettent les
moyens depuis un moment et qui sont
novateurs je peux vous dire que cette
recentralisation d'guisé nous inquiète
fortement parce que nous avons peur de
perdre les prérogatives que nous avons
de perdre le le le côté imaginatif que
nous avons pour devoir repasser sous les
fourches codines d'une ARS qui pour
l'instant n'a absolument pas les moyens
des ambitions dont vous
parlezcoup chers collègues madame la
ministre vous souhaitez intervenir je
vous en prie je voudrais simplement
quand même rappeler j'entends madame la
sénatrice vos vos arguments j'ai
moi-même lorsque j'été présidente de la
commission reçu madame Pirez Baon qui
m'a présenté aussi son rapport et c'est
elle fait de nombreuses préconisations
d' d'ailleurs et l'une des
préconisations qu'elle fait justement
c'est de proposer cette proposer cette
fusion dépendance et puis soins pour
plus
d'efficacité bon je je non mais vous
avez le droit d'être en désaccord mais
en plus c'est demandé également et
souvent on nous demande de ne pas être à
l'écoute écoutez c'est également demandé
par certaines collectivités
territoriales certains présidents et
présidentes de département pour plus
d'efficience mais je tiens à vous
rassurer madame madame la sinatrice si
vous me le permettez on n'est vraiment
pas dans une démarche j'allais dire
comptable le le but c'est effectivement
faire en sorte que l'action publique
soit plus efficace et y compris en terme
de denier voilà ce que j'avais à dire à
madame la
sénatrice merci Madame la Ministre bien
je vais donc mettre au voix cet
amendement qui je vous le rappelle a
recueilli deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté je vais continuer avec
l'amendement 388 rectifié c'est madame
guotta je vous en prie monie oui merci
donc je vais présenter l'amendement de
ma collègue Nathalie de lâre en fait
donc cet article qui concerne bien
évidemment cet article 37 donc dans
lequel les soins dépendances les
sections soins et dépendants sont
fusionnés pour les départements
volontaires euh et c'est un amendement
en fait elle propose une double
expérimentation c'est-à-dire je vais
m'expliquer certains départements
pourront effectivement transférer la pas
établissement à l'ARS en vue de la
fusion des sections soins et dépendances
comme le prévoit l'article initial et il
y aurait une deuxième expérimentation en
parallèle pour d'autres départements qui
pourront exercer eux-mêmes la
tarification de la section soins
toujours dans le cadre d'un forfait
global fusionnant les sections soins et
dépendance l'idée de dire que la
comparaison de ces deux expérimentations
permettrait de véf la meilleure solution
dans un souci de bonne gestion
financière et la garantie d'un vrai
maillage territorial et de recherche de
la solution la plus pertinente pour les
résidents et leurs
familles merci chers collègu l'avis de
la
commission merci madame la Présidente
cet amendement qui réécrit l'article 37
pour mettre en place une expérimentation
croisée d'une part du pilotage de la
section dépendance par la RS et d'autre
part du pilotage de la section soin par
le Département ce faisant il rend la
situation plus complexe encore qu'elle
ne l'est aujourd'hui en dissociant la
fixation du montant des dotations de
leur financement dans la perspective de
réussir une réforme structurelle de
financement des éepad il il importe
d'expérimenter un dispositif qui soit
opérant et apporte de véritables
enseignements je vous précise par
ailleurs que l'adoption de cet
amendement écraserait la rédaction
proposée par la commission qui prévoit
une véritable expérimentation de la
fusion des sections soins et dépendan je
vous propose donc le retrait de cet
amendement sinon ce serait un avis
défavorable merci beaucoup madame la
ministre votre avis merci madame la
Présidente donc votre amendement propose
de remplacer l'article donc 37 par une
expérimentation sur la fusion des
sections soins et dépendances des épad
de façon symétrique pour les ARS et les
départ appartement sur la forme
contrairement à ce qu'indique l'exposé
des motifs les modifications cela a été
dit les modifications législatives que
vous proposez ne comporte pas de
dispositions relatives à une fusion des
sections tarifaires soins et dépendan
comme cela est envisagé le texte propose
seulement une mesure de réciprocité sur
la fixation du forfait soins qui
pourrait être donc confié au département
et inversement le forfait dépendance qui
pourrait lui être confié aux ARS par
ailleurs dans votre amendement la
question des financements n'est elle pas
non plus abordée il serait donc envisagé
que les conseils départementaux puissent
engager des dépenses de la branche
autonomie ou que les les ARS engagent
des dépenses départementales sans que le
cadre ne soit précisé ni les mécanismes
de gouvernance de responsabilité et de
pilotage surtout votre proposition ne
conduit pas à simplifier le financement
des des épad une simplification
effectivement qu'on appelle de notre de
nos vœux donc pour toutes ces raisons je
suis défavor
merci Madame la Ministre bien deux avis
défavorables sur cet amendement 388
rectifié qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté nous passons maintenant
à 14 amendements et 5 sous-amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
nous allons commencer par l'amendement
303 présenté au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales je vous en prie madame
la
rapporteur merci madame la
Présidente la fusion des sections soins
et dépendances pour le financement des
épades comporterait de nombreuses
avantag pour les établissements et
rendrait le système plus laésible pour
l'ensemble des acteurs toutefois la
mesure proposée à l'article 37 qui est à
la fois ça été rappelé pérenne et
facultative pourrait paradoxalement
avoir pour effet de générer des
complexités complémentair et de laisser
s'installer dans la durée des disparités
plus profondes entre les départements
cet amendement vise donc à transformer
cette mesure en une véritable
expérimentation celle-ci pourra être
déployée sur une durée de 3 ans à
compter du 1er janvier 2025 dans un
maximum de 10 départements
volontaires cette expérimentation
donnerait lieu à une évaluation par la
CNSA et à la remise au Parlement 6 mois
avant son terme d'un rapport envisageant
les conditions de sa pérenisation et de
sa
généralisation
merci
beaucoup nous allons donc passer au
sous-amendement le
1360 présenté par Madame
ponemmonge merci madame la Présidente
alors les écologistes soutiennent la
mesure de l'article 39 quant à son
principe mais ne ne son des amendements
que nous allons défendre ou qui sont
défendus par d'autres notamment de
modifier la date d'option pour l'entrée
dans le
dispositif des 2025 pour les
départements qui souhaitent opter D25
pour le nouveau régime unifié de
financement la mesure prévoit une
dérogation jusqu'au 31 mars pour la
transmission au service de l'État de la
délibération certains départements
soutiennent la mesure proposé par
l'article 39 mais alerte sur le temps
nécessaire de discussion préalable à
leur adhésion étant donné qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une expérimentation enfin
jusqu'à présent mais d'une option
irréversible du financement il convient
de laisser le temps non seulement à
l'Association des départements de France
d'analyser les modalités de la réforme
mais à chaque département d'en mesurer
les impacts pour lui-même à titre
d'exemple vice-président de la métropole
de Lyon que j'ai consulté estime qu'il
ne sera pas possible de s'engager dans
le dispositif de fusion prévu si la date
butoire du 31 mars 2024 était maintenue
l'amendement 303 de la rapporteur visant
à transformer cette mesure en une
expérimentation à la qu les départements
pourront se porter candidats nous nous
la soutenons au même titre que dans le
dispositif de l'article initial ce délai
du 31 mars semble rester précoce et ce
sous-amendement à l'amendement 303 vise
à laisser 3 mois supplémentaires ce qui
est le minimal minima pour se porter
candidat en repoussant au 30 juin 24 la
date butoire et cet amendement je tiens
à dire est soutenu par la Fédération
hospitalière de France merci chers
collègues le sous-amendement 1360 madame
rulin merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre C ce sous-amendement pardon
va dans le même sens de ce qui vient
d'être présenté par notre collègue nous
souscrivons à la nouvelle rédaction par
la Commission de cet article 37 qui vise
à transformer la fusion entre les deux
sections qu'on évoque qui au départ dans
la rédaction initiale était irréversible
et qui risquait de creuser des
inégalités entre les départements de le
transformer donc dans la nouvelle
rédaction en une
expérimentation et nous proposons aussi
de donner un délai plus important au
département volontaire qui voudrait
s'engager dans cette expérimentation
parce que vous sembliez dire je vais
j'ai
peut-être déformer encore que non je ne
pense pas vos propos madame la ministre
mais vous vous aviez vous sembliez dire
ça va être des transferts financiers
mais en fait il y a pas vraiment de ce
technique quoi il y a pas vraiment de
problème derrière bon on sait trop ici
que des transferts financiers se passent
pas toujours très bien et que pour les
collectivités les départements en
l'occurrence il peut y avoir un manque à
gagner très important et donc
effectivement laisser du temps pour ceux
qui veulent s'y engager nous semble
intéressant et effectivement le fait que
ça devienne une expérimentation
permettra de tirer tous les
enseignements de cette fusion y compris
parce que ça me semble ble très
important et je souscris en partie à ce
que disait Monique Lubin tout à l'heure
sur le fait que il ne doit pas s'agir
d'une
recentralisation mais au contraire de
d'assurer le reste à charge pour les
familles le moins élevé possible et puis
qu'on qu'on finance enfin au niveau où
ça doit l'être
c'est ces établissements qui qui qui
accueillent pardon nos nos anciens
situation de dépendance
merci collègue monsieur Chassin le
sous-amendement
1375 rectifié merci madame la Présidente
euh
bon monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre
euh effectivement je suis d'accord avec
la proposition de madame le rapporteur
mais le département peut très bien
rester chef de fil dans ce qui concerne
la prise en charge du grand âge même si
effectivement la le financement soin
autonomie est un progrès hein par la
branche autonomie le financement des
deux sections c'est un progrès pour tous
les départements et c'était prévu dans
le rapport Libo et c'était vraiment une
avancée on revient en arrière mais je
suis d'accord effectivement ce que vient
de proposer à
l'expérimentation alors l'amendement 303
effectivement de madame le
rapporteur
maintenant propose une expérimentation
mais comp compte tenu des délais requis
pour permettre au département d'évaluer
donc c'est financement et les effets d'
d'impact de ce choix parce que en fait
on ne dans la dans votre proposition
madame le ministre vous ne vous ne
n'indiquez pas les remboursements des
tickets modérateurs il y a absolument
c'est un flou complet donc tout ça je
pense que c'est bien de de faire une
expérimentation mais on pourrait pour la
réflexion des départements effectivement
repousser au 30 juin 2024 au lieu du au
lieu
de permettre de rentrer le plus grand
nombre de départements dans le niveau
dispositif le repousser la date de
décision non pas en mars mais en juin 30
juin merci si chers collègues le
sous-amendement 1377 qui le présente
Madame
Ferré donc ce ce sous-amendement
s'inscrit dans la même démarche que mes
collègues ont déjà évoqué en écho
ensuite de l'amendement de la rapporteur
l'amendement 303 qui propose donc la
mise en œuvre la mise en place d'une
expérimentation que nous soutiendrons
avec ce sous-amendement qui vise à
décaler donner un peu plus de temps et
puis je ne reprends pas tous les
arguments qui ont été donnés par les
interlocuteurs précédents merci chers
collègues enfin Madame Guillotin le 1300
78 sous amendement également oui
rapidement donc pour dire
qu'effectivement nous saluons et ce
rapprochement des des sections soins et
dépendances dans un financement unique
que le volet de l'expérimentation nous
SEM proposé par la Commission nous
semble une bonne solution et du coup je
ne redonnerai pas les les arguments pour
pouvoir donner un petit délai
supplémentaire pour mettre en place
cette
expérimentation merci beaucoup bien nous
passons maintenant à l'amendement 1029
c'est madame ponémong qui le
présente
je vous en prie chers
collègues le 1029 qui est en amendement
identique avec le suivant merci madame
la Présidente cet amendement de mon
collègue grégoryi blanc vise à prévoir
la consultation préalable du président
du conseil départemental sur la fixation
du montant du forfait unique dès lors
que sa collectivité aura manifesté le
souhait de fusionner les sections soins
et dépendan je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame Ferré le
1193 défendu ou non c'est Monsieur
canner monsieur président pas re défendu
du tout madame la Présidente on va le
défendre madame la ministre en fait on
est sur un débat qui est extrêmement
intéressant puisque nous sommes en train
de d'imaginer des dispositifs
expérimentaux qui visent à compenser
l'incurie de 78 mois de
gouvernement c'est bien ça dont il
s'agit 78 mois de gouvernement la loi la
grande loi autonomie promise par le
présid par le
président par le président Macron se
résume aujourd'hui à une expérimentation
pour des départements volontaires visant
à fusionner la section dépenses et la
section
dépendance excusez-moi on est quand même
très très loin de l'objectif initial et
votre serviteur qui vient de d'effectuer
un déplacement en Outremer je peux vous
dire que la situation dans les
territoires et départements d'outremè
est catastrophique sur l'hébergement des
personnes âgées donc voilà nous
proposons des amendement de repli par
rapport à l'expérimentation initiale qui
avait été imaginée très bien
euh ce n'est sûrement pas l'idéal madame
la ministre je vous le dis comme je le
pense
euh les financements ne sont pas la
hauteur vous avez créé une 5e branche
mais il y a pas de feuille sur cette
branche euh et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui a gérer l'accueil des
personnes âgées avec des bouts de ficell
nous le regrettons néanmoins il y a un
partenaire que nous voulons défendre à
savoir les conseils départementaux et
l'amendement que propose madame Ferré
que j'ai l'honneur de défendre le
1193 vise à ce qu' à minima pour les
situations où l'expérience serait menée
il puisse y avoir une consultation
systématique des départements de manière
à pouvoir les mettre autour de la table
sur un sujet qui les regarde
prioritairement merci monsieur le
Président nous allons continuer avec le
1186 et Madame Ferré je vous en pris
cher collègues merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre donc cet
amendement vise je dirais à bien prendre
en compte le le reste à charge des
résidents dans les épad en particulier
qu'on tiennent bien compte de leurs
ressources quand on parle de reste à
charge car en effet les résidents en
épal les personnes âgées les plus
pauvres les plus fragiles les plus isolé
ils sont nombreuses elles sont
confrontées à des taux d'effort
considérabl et seul une partie 24 % peut
couvrir ses frais de
séjour vous vous vous arrêterez le
peuvent couvrir ses frais de séjour euh
voilà je suis perdu via ses revenus
courants le séjour en établissement est
coûteux pour tous mais il est
parfaitement insoutenable pour les plus
modestes le système actuel est par
ailleurs peu justifieré globalement ce
sont les plus modestes qui ne sont pas
aidés à la hauteur de leurs besoins les
les ménages modestes sont moins aidés
que les plus aisés et la courbe des
soutiens présente ainsi une forme de U
plutôt que j en ce qui ce qui démontre
que la redistribution à l'œuvre
actuellement si le gouvernement a choisi
de ne pas introduire dans le PLFSS de
mesures radicales pour réduire ce reste
à charge et bien nous proposons ici une
solution de second rang certes en
prévoyant que euh tous la participation
journalière soit vraiment calculé selon
les revenus des résidents si si cher
collègue nous continuons avec la
présentation du l'amendement 699
rectifié madame
ponmonge merci madame la Présidente
alors cet amendement vise à prévoir que
le reste à vivre des résidents des
épades dans les départements fusionnant
leur section soins et dépendan soit
défin après avis du Conseil national des
politiques de lutte contre la pauvreté
et l'exclusion sociale parce que comme
je l'ai dit hier le Secours Catholique
vient de le dire en France la pauvreté
[Musique]
s'intensifie augmente et en plus se
féminise alors il est je crois que là il
y a un manque d'expertise quant à la du
gouvernement quant à la lutte contre la
pauvreté parce que tel que l'avance le
rapport garantir la prise en charge des
personnes âgées en établissement
encadrer leur rapport de leur reste sa
charge remis en juin 2023 par la députée
Christine pieres B à la première
ministre je cite il ne peut être
question de négliger la prise en charge
en établissement et l'accès de tous à
des séjours qui au demeurant ne sont la
plupart du temps pas choisi mais subi or
parmi les résidents en épad les
personnes âés les plus pauvres les plus
fragiles les plus isolés sont nombreuses
elles sont confronté à des taux d'effort
considérables notez que seul une petite
partie 24 % un/4 donc peut couvrir ses
frais de séjour via ses revenus courants
le rapport évoque un modèle contre
contre redistributif le séjour en
établissement est coûteux pour tous mais
il est particulièrement insoutenable
pour les plus modestes le système actuel
est par ailleurs peu justifiés les plus
modestes ne sont pas aidés à la hauteur
de leurs besoins les ménages les ménages
modestes sont moins aidés que les plus
aisés par conséquent selon ce même
rapport il est donc possible en
établissement comme à domicile de
demander à chaque
de contribuer selon ses moyens et d'être
soutenu selon ses besoins c'est l'objet
de notre amendement merci chers
collègues nous allons continuer avec
l'amendement 1190 car le précédent tombe
c'est Madame Ferré qui le
présente merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre donc par cet
amendement nous visons à prévoir la
consultation du président du conseil
départemental sur la fixation du du
montant du forfait unique dès lors que
la collectivité se serait inscrite donc
dans ce souhait de de fusion des
sections soins et dépendan euh voilà
c'est aussi rappeler le rôle essentiel
incontournable que les départements les
conseils départementaux doivent jouer
dans cette nouvelle approche merci chers
collègues nous continuons avec le 567
rectifié monsieur
Chassin madame la présidente madame le
mieur chers collègues donc très
rapidement nous considérons aussi que
c'est très important que le département
reste chef de fil mais cont tenu des
délais requis donc pour permettre au
département d'évaluer finement les
impacts de ce choix pour que il y ait
une fusion effectivement soin
indépendant c'est de réunir les
assemblées délibérantes une dérogation
au 30 juin 2024 plutôt qu'au 31 mars
permettrait l'entrée d'un plus grand
nombre de départements dans le nouveau
dispositif je voudrais rappeler plus que
près de 90 % des gestionnaires des
maisons de retraite des des éepades et
des présidentses du conseil
d'administration souhaite effectivement
que la les sections soit indépendant
soient bien prises en charge par la
branche autonomie et les soins et donc
ça c'est vraiment très très important
pour l'avenir parce que actuellement
s'il y a que il y aura une distorsion
entre les départements et c'est vraiment
une régression il faut repartir dans la
politique
du grand âge telle qu'elle avait été
préconisée en 2020 je sais bien qu'il y
a eu il y a des problèmes au niveau du
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
le covid on peut pas nier les dépenses
énormes pour le covid une amélioration
aussi avec le séure de la santé mais vu
la dépendance qui va arriver entre 2020
et 2040 il faut reprendre une dynamique
dans la politique du grand âge et
prévoir vraiment pour les départ
département une prise en charge de de la
section soins dépendance par l'ARS merci
merci cher collègue le 601 rectifié
madame Guillotin
oui donc c'est on est toujours sur le
même sujet effectivement donc on repart
sur l'article 37 qui vise à créer un
cadre rénové et simplifié pour
financement des épad donc tout ça a été
dit il serait mis en place dans les
départements volontaires à partir de
2025 effectivement euh je l'ai précisé
tout à l'heure comme si cette mesure
présente effectivement une avanceée
importante sur le principe elle pourrait
être améliorée en modifiant la date
d'option pour l'entrée dans le
dispositif en 2025 cette date d'option
fixée au 31 mars 2024 et la date limite
pour la transmission au service de
l'État de la délibération du département
contenu des délais requis pour permettre
au département d'évaluer les impacts de
ce choix réunir les assemblées
délibérante le report au 30 juin 2024
permettrait l'entrée d'un plus grand
nombre de départements dans le nouveau
dispositif donc c'est un report de date
chers collègues madame ponémon le 700
rectifié défendu je vous remercie nous
continuons avec Madame Brulin ou à pour
défendu merci beaucoup enfin le
1188 défendu également merci chers
collègues alors nous passons à
l'amendement
1182 puisque le 1028 rectifié tombe
est-ce que Madame Corine Ferré peut le
présenter merci chers collègue oui merci
madame la Présidente euh nous proposons
donc avec cet
amendement
de enfin revenir pardon pardon en 2020
la concertation grand âge et autonomie
avait conduit à avancer l'idée de
procéder à une expérimentation de
certains départements d'une compétence
euh exclusive au département et dans
d'autres d'une compétence exclusive de
la de la RS s'il le souhaitait cette
expérimentation devait permettre de
déterminer le meilleur cadre de gestion
pour généraliser sur l'ensemble du
territoire cet amendement propose donc
de reprendre cette solution d'une
gouvernance départementale afin
d'assurer d'évaluer sur pièces le
meilleur service rendu à la population
l'objectif à terme demeure celui de
basculer vers un système cible donc
c'est l'expérimentation miroir que nous
pourrions proposer je rappelle que cet
amendement a été proposé par l'ASS ition
des départements solidaires merci chers
collègues bien alors madame la
rapporteur votre avis sur l'ensemble de
ces amendements et sous-amendements
merci madame la Présidente alors
concernant les sous-amendements 1370
1371 1375 1377 et
1378 qui propose de décaler la date du
31 mars au 30 juin pour que les
départements puissent transmettre leur
délibération c'est un avis favorable
tous les autres amendements sont
incompatibl avec l'amendement de la
commission c'est donc un avis
défavorable alors si on rentre un petit
peu plus dans le détail les amendements
567 601 700 930 et
1188 sont satisfaits par les
sous-amendement précédents les
amendements 1029 et
1193 qui prévoit une concertation avec
le président du conseil départemental
sur le montant du forfait unique soins
et dépendan semble contraire au principe
de l'expérimentation c'est bien un
pilotage par la RS qu'il s'agit
d'expérimenter étant entendu bien sûr
que les département conserveront pour
leur part la compétence de l'aide
sociale à
l'hébergement concernant les amendements
1030 et
1190 qui prévoit un avis de l'Assemblée
des départements de France sur les
modalité de détermination et
d'allocation du forfait global unique il
va de soit que pour que le dispositif
fonctionne les département doivent être
associés à son élaboration euh
l'amendement
1190 86 pardon qui impose la prise en
compte des ressources des résidents dans
la fixation de leur participation
journalière est satisfait il sera
garanti aux personnes accueillies un
montant minimal laissé à leur
disposition et le dernier l'amendement 6
199 qui prévoit un avis du CNLE sur ce
montant minimal garantie ce conseil peut
de sa propre initiative proposé au
pouvoir public les mesures qui lui
paraissent pouvoir améliorer la lutte
contre l'exclusion sociale je vous
remerci madame la rapporteur madame la
ministre sur ces amendements s'il vous
plaît sous-amendement merci Madame
madame la Présidente alors vos
sous-amendement donc vise à reculer la
date limite de candidature en 2024 pour
les départements souhaitant donc donc
participer à la fusion des sections
soins et et dépendance des éepad alors
ce délai supplémentaire vous le
justifiez bien sûr et et doit permettre
au département d'analyser les modalités
de la réforme et aux collectivités
volontaires d'en mesurer les impacts
alors bien sûr je je je partage
l'intérêt d'un report de la date butoire
au au 31 mars 2024 nous souhaitons
effectivement donner le temps nécessaire
aux échanges avec les départements pour
leur permettre bien sûr de se décider
dans les meilleures conditions et en
toute connaissance de cause bien sûr
cependant ce report doit rester
compatible avec les délais de gestion
nécessaire à la préparation des
transferts financiers à comptter du 1er
janvier
2025 donc après analyse il apparaît
qu'un report au 30 juin serait bien sûr
trop tardif pour permettre une mise en
place dans les meilleures conditions
donc je vous confirme cependant
cependant que nous allons décaler cette
date autant que possible à grand minimum
un mois donc avec cette assurance je
vous demande de bien vouloir retirer
votre amendement sinon j'y serai
défavorable pour ce qui est des
sous-amendements
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'amendement
euh alors alors pour ce qui est des
amendements 1029
1193 même avis que Madame la rapporteur
et donc
défavorable je n'ai pas sur une feuille
unique donc voilà alors pour ce qui est
euh de l'amendement 1029 et 1080 1193
pardon donc votre amendement vise à
instaurer une concertation obligatoire
du président du conseil départemental
lors de la fixation du forfait global
relatif au SO vous l'avez dit Madame la
Ministre on peut on peut avancer oui oui
nous sommes au 1186 ah pardon je vous en
prie je vous en prie ah pardon oui
1186 madame
madame la ministre pardonnez-moi vous
avez bien donné un avis défavorable sur
le 1029 et le 1193ou tout à fait j'ai
dit même avis que Madame Lapp absolument
donc maintenant le 1186 et maintenant le
1900 1186 très bien donc votre
amendement vise à vise à tenir compte
des ressources des résidents pour fixer
leur niveau de contribution à la future
section unique soins et entretien de
l'autonomie lors du passage au forfait
unique la participation des résidents
deviendra forfaitaire et uniformisée
quel que soit leur lieu d'implantation
cela permettra de renforcer
effectivement l'équité de traitement
entre les territoires concernés avec une
convergence des restes à charge on sait
on connaît toutes et tous la disparité
qui existe d'un département à un autre
par ailleurs la mise en œuvre d'une
gestion en fonction des ressources et
d'une grande complexité on le sait pour
les épades cela a été dit et c'est
Harbour de la simplification qui est
justement recherché la prise en compte
des ressources devrait en outre être
assortie de conditions pour éviter les
effets de sélection susceptible
d'exclure je dis bien d'exclure les
résidents aux ressources les plus
faibles ou encore de dérives de reste à
charge enfin les travaux préalables sont
encore nécessaires pour déterminer
déterminer pardon quelle catégorie de
ressources euh de ressources
privilégiées pour ces raisons donc je
suis défavorable à vos à votre
amendement le
1186 le 699 rectifié alors le 699
rectifié votre amendement vise à prévoir
que le reste à vivre des résidents même
chose en épad dans les départements
ayant opté pour un régime de
tarification adapté soit soumis à l'avis
du Conseil national des politiques de
lutte contre la pauvreté et l'exclusion
sociale la problématique du reste à
charge en épad et donc du reste à vivre
des résidents était véritablement un
sujet important qui a effectivement été
analysé euh dans le récent rapport de
madame la députée pieres bon et je rends
hommage bien sûr à la qualité du travail
qui a été mené par Madame la madame la
députée à ce titre je tiens à rappeler
que dans le cadre de la fusion des
sections permises dans cet par cet
article la participation financière des
résidents au titre des dépenses
d'entretien de l'autonomie sera
forfaitaire je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
et uniforme sur tous les territoires
concernés donc il y aura une certaine
équité cela permettra de réduire les
inégalités traitement actuellement
constatés entre résidents de
départements différents voire entre
résidents d'un même département en
conséquence je suis donc défavorable à
cet
amendement pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 1030 et rectificatif et
1190 alors amendement qui vise à prévoir
obligatoirement l'avis de l'Assemblée
des départements de France sur les
modalités de détermination et
d'allocation du forfait global unique
relatif aux soins et et à l'entretien de
l'autonomie la mesure de fusion des
sections a un impact sur les
collectivités territoriales dès lors
l'ensemble des décrets d'application de
l'article 37 du présent projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale fera
l'objet d'une consultation du Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes
instance issue du Comité des finances
locales je considère donc en fait que
votre amendement est satisfait et c'est
pourquoi je demande le retrait ou le
rejet
alors pareil pour les amendements 1000
alors 567 601 700 9 930 et
1188 donc c'est le sujet il concerne les
délais ça a déjà été donc évoqué donc je
vais vous demander je reste sur la même
ligne retrait sinon
rejet alors pour l'amendement 1028
rectificatif et
1192 alors qui vise à instaurer une
expérimentation sur une mesure miroir du
du forfait unique relatif aux soins et à
l'entretien de l'autonomie dans laquelle
les conseils départementaux seront
seraient compétents et non plus l'agence
régionale de santé pour en fixer le
montant après analyse et sans a priori
une telle mesure devrait nécessairement
s'accompagner du transfert d'autres
compétences actuellement détenu
exclusive ou conjointement par les ARS
notamment ce qui concerne et vous le
savez la signature des contrats pluri
annuels d'objectif et de moyens
l'évaluation de la qualité de
l'accompagnement dans les éepad ça n'est
pas rien l'évaluation également des
besoins en soins des résidents la
médicalisation des éepad aussi bien sur
le volet financier qu'organisationnel la
validation et le contrôle des documents
budgétaires les inspections et les
contrôles de ces établissements
l'expertise en matière de circuit du
médicament la coordination entre le
sanitaire et le médico-social en résumé
cette mesure soulève ainsi de nombreuses
interrogations sur bien des domaines et
et des interrogation très concrète
est-ce que les départements discuteront
désormais de l'organisation d'une
pharmacie à usage intérieur de
l'opportunité d'un passage au tarif
global ou de soins innovant les
transferts financiers que vous évoquez
supposent par ailleurs une forme de je
le dis ça va être fort une forme de
décentralisation de la sécurité sociale
ces discussions ont ement eu lieu en
commission il y a quelques jours et ont
abouti à ne pas voter justement cette
mesure partant de ce constat et après
une analyse attentive des implications
pour les départements j'ai mets donc un
avis plus que
défavorable merci beaucoup madame la
ministre bien alors je vais commencer à
mettre au voix les C sous-amendements
identiques et j'ai un certain nombre de
de demandes de d'explication de vote je
vais commencer par Monsieur
H
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre alors ce cet amendement que je
salue de de la commission nous permet
d'aborder cette question au fond de de
l'autonomie dans dans sa globalité de
l'organisation de l'autonomie alors
évidemment cette loi et autonomie on
l'attend depuis un certain temps c'est
une forme de serpent de mer mais je
crois pas qu'il faille faire un conflit
de paternité hein sur serpent de mer il
y a certain temps qu'on attend ce ce ce
cette loi autonomie mais au fond on voit
bien que dans l'organisation des des
épades on est arrivé au au bout d'un
système à la fois pour la qualité de vie
dans ces épades le le le l'organisation
à l'intérieur des épades le personnel et
puis la complexité je crois que la il y
aurait pas eu d'affaair hor pa si les
contrôles avaient mieux fonctionné on
l'a vu hein le sénateur bone la
sénatrice qui était en charge aussi de
cette question l'ont l'ont l' l'ont
mesuré et donc on est arrivé au bout du
système et je crois que l'idée de de
fusionner soit soins et dépendance est
absolument indispensable mais euh à ce
moment-là ça va se poser la question de
de l'organisation et je pense que et
c'est c'est c'est le sens de mon
intervention ça doit pas du tout être
l'occasion d'une recentralisation mais
au contraire un saut qualitatif euh vers
plus de décentralisation encore et c'est
l'occasion de se poser euh la question
aussi de de la gouvernance d'où la
l'indispensable lo autonomie pour des
questions de financement mais aussi de
gouvernance je pense qu'on est arrivé au
bout euh avec la CNSA dans la
gouvernance de la question autonomie et
que s'il y a une loi autonomie il me
semble que les départements dans la
gouvernance même de la branche doivent
être beaucoup plus présents pour sans
doute franchir encore un pas au niveau
de la la décentralisation et rendre le
le meilleur service public possible au
plus près du terrain je vous remercie
merci chers collègue monsieur Milon pour
une explication de vote je vous en prie
chers
collègues merci madame la Présidente
j'aurais pu dire ce ce que vient de dire
Olivier h donc je vais prolonger en
disant à Monsieur canner en particulier
que ça fait pas 7 ans qu'on attend une
loi autonomie mais 12 je me souviens
très bien qu'ici madame deloné à
l'époque avait déjà fait un discours sur
la possibilité d'une grande loi
autonomie qu'on n jamais vu le deè point
c'est que j'ai présidé vendredi dernier
l'assemblée générale de la Fédération
hospitalière de France pour la région
sud provenal Côte d'Azur et j'ai été
étonné de voir que tous les médecins
coordinateurs et tous les directeurs
despad sont demandeurs d'un d'un
financeur unique et que tous à à mon
grand étonnement était plutôt favorable
à un financeur unique ARS qui un
financeur unique département donc la le
projet de loi tel qu'il est présenté
actuellement va plutôt dans le sens de
la demande faite par les directeurs
d'pad et médecins coordinateur au moins
de la région sud pour le reste je ne
sais pas mais au moins de la région sud
enfin je rejoins complètement Chantal de
Scine dans son amendement y compris
d'ailleurs dans la modification au 30
juin ce qui me semble être une bonne
chose je voudrais madame la ministre
vous dire que si les ARS devenaient les
finanurs unique ce qui semblait être
souhaité par beaucoup de monde il serait
peut-être utile par ailleurs qu'on
repense à la déc réisation des ARS et
faire en sorte que les présidents de
région puissent enfin que présider les
conseils d'administration merci cher
collègue j'is madame doanau pour une
explication de vote
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègue je voudrais
appuyer la proposition de notre
rapporteur sur la branche autonomie en
effet c'est une opportunité qu'il faut
saisir mais avec un un un degré dans le
temps moi je pense que collectivement on
peut se dire que on gère l'indigence
hein dans le secteur de l'autonomie même
s'il y a eu une branche autonomie qui a
été créée même si elle a été abondée on
voit bien sur le terrain que nos épades
souffrent alors finalement c'est c'est
le prix aussi pour les familles qui
reste très très lourd c'est les
difficultés du personnel c'est les
difficultés de recrutement c'est les
difficultés pour les directeurs et puis
on on a vu un fond vient d'être abondé
pour soutenir les épades qui ont
souffert de l'inflation tout ça c'est
très bien mais globalement on ne met pas
suffisamment pour ce secteur-là la Cour
des comptes avait euh produit il y a
quelques années déjà un rapport pour
dire que les personnes âgées qui
arrivent en épad arrivent de plus en
plus euh avec des pathologies lourdes
des maladies chroniques et qu'il fallait
penser justement au transfert vers
plutôt les ARS alors donc moi je pense
que ça va dans le bon sens mais il faut
peut-être comme le propose la commission
aller avec l'expérimentation je voudrais
euh aussi indiquer que dans le cadre de
cette expérimentation il faut absolument
interroger les deux évaluations qui sont
faites l'évaluation Patos qui est faite
par le domaine du soin et l'évaluation
GMP qui est faite pour la dépendance par
les départements on voit bien que sur le
terrain ce qui nous est dit c'est que
souvent ces évaluations sont en décalage
avec les besoins en fait de des
résidents elle arrive souvent en
décalage et donc le le budget ne
correspond pas avec le besoin des
résidents donc il faudra interroger ces
deux évaluations d'abord dans le temps
et en essayant de contemporanéiser si je
puis dire et surtout de mettre en face
les moyens qu'il faut merci merci chers
collègues madame pumirol pour une
explication de vote également ensuite ce
sera monsieur Chassin
oui merci madame la Présidente je ne
comprends pas très bien pourquoi vous ne
voulez pas accepter l'expérimentation
miroir vous dites vouloir simplifier
mais en fait pour vous ça veut dire
simple simplement que vous
allez c'est obligatoirement la RS qui
doit avoir la la compétence et la
gouvernance et les départements parce
que les départements selon vous ne
seraient pas CAPAES de répondre à des
questions purement médicales en
particulier vous avez cité l'exemple de
savoir est-ce qu'il faut créer une puui
ou est-ce qu'il faut pas en créer une
mais inversement est-ce que les ARS sont
capable de suivre le volet dépendance
qui vient d'être évoqué par par ma
collègue éisabeth douanau est-ce qu'il
est capable est-ce que l'ARS est capable
de bien suivre le volet social volet
solidarité qui est la compétence propre
des département donc moi je vous serais
favorable au fait qu'on puisse faire au
au minimum l'expérience miroir qui
permettrait d'évaluer sur pièce quelle
est la meilleure dans chaque cas des
expériences puisque vous vous dites
qu'effectivement il y a des départements
qui sont volontaires sur la reprise par
la RS des et la fusion des deux des deux
compétences mais en fait ces
départements sont volontaires parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens tout
simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens financiers et s'il y avait une
aide suffisante de l'État dans ce
domaine là il il ne serait pas contraint
de se j'allais dire de se défaire d'une
compétence qui est qui est vraiment une
des compétences propres du département
donc soit on donne les moyens et on
continue à faire une gestion bicéphale
j'allais dire mais soit à
minima faute de mieux donnez-nous
l'occasion de prouver pour les
départements qui en ont envie leur
action innovant leur action dans le
terme de en terme de dépendance et qui
leur permettent de continuer à être chef
de fil et responsable de ces épad merci
ma cher collègue monsieur Chassin
également pour une explication de vote
et ensuite je passerai la parole à
Madame Ambert
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues donc je
voterai effectivement pour l'amendement
de madame de madame le rapporteur bon il
est évident que par rapport à ce qui
était prévu euh bon c'est une régression
mais c'est bien d'aller dans ce sens et
je rappelle que 80 % des personnes qui
sont à la manœuvre pour gérer des épad
souhait qu'il y ait ces deux
euh qu' ait les soins et la dépendance
fusionné et financé par par la RS je
voudrais dire après ce que m'a dit le
rapporteur général que l'patos et le
soin sont vraiment complètement
intriqués et donc c'est une même c'est
c'est il faut que ce soit effectivement
fusionné les départements peuvent très
bien rester chef de fil ils vont être
chef de fil pour le maintien à domicile
avec les siades mais le département a
besoin de
renforcer le maintien à domicile et
lorsque les personnes vont rentrer si ce
maintien à domicile peut être renforcé
par les départements parce que les
départements on difficultés budgétaires
si ensuite les personnes vont rentrer en
épad de plus en plus dépendant c'est
déjà le cas on est à des GMP qui sont à
plus de 750 dans les éepads avec euh une
une la moyenne d'âge dans les éepads de
90 ans hein les personnes vont rester
moins d'un an donc il faut absolument
les 50000 emplois à la fin donc du
quinquedin avec pour le remboursement du
ticket modérateur pour les j 5 6 en
fonction des revenus et je voudrais
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Madame le
Ministre tout à l'heure il serait
intéressant pour les secteurs ruraux que
les pharmacies d'officine puissent avoir
puissent être également responsable de
la pharmacie dans les épades je pense
que ça effectivement ça a un coût mais
quand même très minime et ça serait
vraiment très important pour les épades
et consolidés des pharmacie rurale merci
chers collègue madame Ambert je vous en
prie
merci madame la Présidente juste
quelques mots pour dire d'abord je
soutiendrai bien sûr l'amendement de de
la rapporteur et de la et de la
commission dire que je partage les les
propos de Monsieur Milon notre collègue
et tout simplement qu'est-ce que nous
constatons aujourd'hui d'abord le
développement du virage ambulatoire
ensuite une entrée en épad avec un âge
de plus en plus avancé de la part des
des résidents et donc les épas
deviennent plus avec un caractère
sanitaire et donc cette ce rapprochement
et ce ce transfert vers vers les agences
me paraît tout à fait correspondre à la
réalité de ce que nous observons
aujourd'hui sur le terrain je pense pas
que les conseils départementaux que je
je défends puisque je je je siège encore
au sein d'un conseil départemental en
seront lesés bien au contraire merci
chers collègues j'ai madame ponmong pour
explication de vote et ensuite ce sera
madame Lubin oui merci madame la
Présidente B pour toutes les raisons qui
ont été énoncées moi enfin nous ne
sommes guerre favorable à à l'amendement
miroir
euh même si la seule crainte ça peut
être de dire que les épad doivent rester
des lieux de vie avant des avant d'être
des lieux de soin qui doit y avoir c'est
un peu une crainte philosophique je
dirais enfin de représentation par
contre moi je pense madame la ministre
que l'année prochaine ça serait bien que
vous proposiez la même chose pour les
Sades je parle des Sades autonomie he
pas des Sades aide et et et
accompagnement c'est-à-dire des services
d'autonomie euh à domicile qui là pour
le coup pourrait être en tarification
unique effectivement s'il y a des Sades
anciennement sad accompagnement euh sous
les gides là par contre enfin sur le
tarificateur unique du département parce
que effectivement enfin les épades n'ont
plus de GIR 4 ils ont même à peine des
Gires 3 ils sont plutôt dans les GIR 1
et GIR 2 donc ils sont très médicalisés
de fait par contre les GIR 4 c'est le
lieu de la prévention c'est vraiment là
pour le coup les détenteurs du enfin les
garant du du virage domiciliaire et je
crois que le département serait mieux
àett de demander que les services
d'autonomie à
domicile est aussi la même réforme et là
pour le coup moi là je défendrais que ça
soit le le département qui soit l'unique
parce que je remarque quand même qu'on
oublie toujours l'aide à Dom
on dit il y a eu 100 millions pour les
éepades non je suis désolé le fond
d'urgence de 100 millions c'est pour les
éepades et les services à domicile il
faut bien toujours marcher sur les deux
jambes et voilà moi je vous propose
l'année prochaine de nous proposer la
même réforme et cette fois-ci avec le
Conseil Général unificateur merci chers
collègu madame Lubin
oui moi
je je j'entends ce que disent mes
collègues effectivement hein euh cette
loi dépendance tout le monde en parle
depuis longtemps Michel de laonet en
parl mais je voudrais quand même lui
rendre un peu justice parce qu'elle a
fait voter un projet de loi d'adaptation
de la société au vieillissement qu'il y
avait des moyens que je me souviens à
l'époque être VP sur ce sujet-là dans
mon département et qu'on avait mis un
certain nombre de choses en place donc
je tenais quand même à lui rendre un
petit peu justice et
pardon et
en règle générale bien sûr pour
l'autonomie et surtout oui le le fameux
virage domiciliaire dont tout le monde
parle il y avait eu quelques moyens à ce
moment-là parce que ce que je voudrais
quand même dire c'est que aujourd'hui on
nous parle encore de virage domiciliaire
on nous parle de de de d'amélioration
des conditions de vie dans les épades
enfin excusez-moi mais pour l'instant se
paye de mot mais on se paye pas beaucoup
d'espèces sonnantes et trèsbchant je
trouve voilà donc chacun effectivement
doit balayer devant sa porte mais là
nous sommes l'année 2023 avec le
gouvernement tel qu'il est aux affaires
depuis 6 ans on a des mots beaucoup de
mots cette année il y a 100 millions
d'euros effectivement ça fait 1 million
d'euros par département rien que dans
mon petit département on a mis 7
millions et demi cette année pour pour
aider les épad et le et les services à
domicile et comme je n'aime pas parler à
la première personne si nous avons fait
beaucoup d'autres départements l'ont
fait aussi voilà donc je voudrais dire
que et je redis simplement le le sens de
mon amendement c'est que en ce moment au
niveau du du gouvernement on ne nous
parle que de faire des économies et donc
dans ce cadrelà je ne vois pas comment
on peut accepter de recentraliser vers
les ARS tant qu'on ne nous met pas en
face l'enveloppe qui va bien avec merci
ma chère collègue j'ai également une
explication d' de la part de monsieur
somumo je vous en prie chers collègues
oui merci madame la Présidente on voit
bien effectivement que il y a d'énormes
différenciations entre les départements
il y a énormément de différenciation
entre chaque établissement dans les
mêmes départements en tout cas ayant été
président de département ayant eu à
gérer nous avons développé un plan de de
réhabilitation de l'ensemble des épades
on voit bien qu'il a nécessité de cette
expérimentation et qui soit miroir parce
qu'effectivement la situation sont un
département peut-être à vouloir rentrer
avec un financement en tout cas une une
une concertation complète ARS mais
d'autres effectivement comme l'a dit
Madame Lubin qui ont développé des des
services des innovations qui font que
les départements sont tout à fait en
capacité de pouvoir satisfaire aux
besoins sanitaires mais pour autant on
voit bien que cette expérimentation est
absolument nécessaire moi je ne pense
pas comme le docteur Chassin que ce soit
une régression c'est une adaptation par
rapport au fait qu'e l' dit Madame doano
que l'entrée dans les épades est de plus
en plus dans un état sanitaire aggravé
et qui a plus de nécessité de soins que
d'accompagnement ce que disait madame
ponémonge même si il y a le cas où il y
a les deux mais on voit bien que pour
avoir un bon accompagnement il faudrait
qu'il y ait un peu moins de sanitaire et
pour avoir plus de sanitaire on Nura pas
le temps de s'occuper de
l'accompagnement d'où la nécessité et
c'est pour ça que j'appuie cette
expérimentation miroir qui me paraît
extrêmement
intéressante merci mon cher collègue
alors je crois qu'il n'y a plus
d'explication de vote je n'en VO pas
alors je vais commencer par mettre au
voix les cinq sous-amendements
identiques qui je vous le rappelle
pardon madame la ministre pardon je vous
en
prie merci madame la Présidente je je je
m'excuse mais je n'ai pas répondu aux 33
donc ce serait peut-être bien que je
puisse y répondre c'est vrai queil y
avait plor de d'amendements et de
sous-amendements j'allais vous demander
de préciser votre votre avis
effectivement mais vous écoutez allez-y
mais je vais d'abord passer au voix les
les cinq sous-amendements et ensuite je
vous demanderai de préciser votre avis
s'ils sont ou non adoptés bien donc mes
chers collègues je vais passer au voix
ces cinq sous-amendements identiques qui
je vous le rappelle ont eu un avis
favorable de la commission et si j'ai
compris un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour ces cinq
sous-amendements identiques bien qui est
contre qui
s'abstient donc ils sont adop
ainsi maintenant je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 303 ainsi sous-amendé qui a
donc eu un avis et je vais demander à la
ministre son avis sur le 303 ainsi
sous-amendé merci bien Madame la la la
présidente donc pour cet amendement je
vais émettre un avis de
sagesse je tiens toutefois à apporter
quelques quelques éléments
d'explication euh je voudrais quand même
cet amendement donc je rappelle vise à
remplacer donc les dispositions de
l'article 37 par une expérimentation de
la fusion des sections soins et
dépendance dans certains départements je
rappelle que la fusion des sections
soins et dépendan je le rappelle est
demandée par de nombreux acteurs y
compris d'ailleurs par les collectivités
territoriales que sont donc les les
départements que nous faisons cette
expérimentation aussi pour pour
atteindre une certaine simplification on
sait qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont
complexes donc plus une simplification
des circuits de financement une
amélioration également de l'équité
euh équité à laquelle j'allais dire nos
compatriotes j'allais dire nous
rappellent parfois à l'ordre quand ils
déménagent se rendent compte
qu'effectivement il y a de grandes
disparité et puis ça permettra également
un renforcement du modèle économique des
épades et il en a été question
effectivement ce matin je rappelle
également et je tiens à rassurer les
conseils départementaux il jouent un
rôle de premiers planans dans la
gouvernance de la politique du grand âge
on le sait c'est pourquoi nous avons
souhaité que cette fusion interviennne
sur la base du volontariat je rappelle
encore c'est la base du volontariat
malgré cela le système d'option a pu je
l'ai vu en tous les cas au travers de
vos interventions a pu susciter des
inquiétudes de par son caractère
irréversible le passage à une
expérimentation permettrait en effet de
palier ces inquiétudes que je partage
elle permettra toujours au Conseil
département Mau qui le souhait
d'expérimenter une fusion des sections à
la charge de la branche autonomie mais
elle permettra également d'évaluer les
résultats et de montrer les apports de
cette fusion apport que bien sûr
j'espère qu'il seront
positifs vous préconisez en fait pour
cette expérimentation le nombre de 10
départements euh moi vous vous proposez
effectivement cela ça semble quand même
être limité il est dommage qu'il ne
puisse pu y avoir qu'une seule phase
d'entrée dans pour ce qui est de
d'entrée pour ce qui est de l'année
prochaine je le regrette un peu en
conséquence et avec cet enjeu de
préciser plus longuement les modalités
et de manière beaucoup plus j'allais
dire concise lors de la navette j' metis
donc un avis de sagesse pour cette
expérimentation encore une fois basée
sur le
volontariat madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur vous souhaitiez intervenir
merci madame la Présidente et je
voudrais répondre à Madame la Ministre
et et parce que je m'étonne un petit peu
de votre avis de sagesse et de votre
prudence en quelque sorte je voulais
rappeler à tous mes collègues que lors
de de l'audition de la ministre des
Solidarités mais aussi dans le cadre de
nos
échanges la ministre nous a dit n'avoir
aucun tabout sur
l'expérimentation aucun problème et
plutôt favorable à l'expérimentation
donc je vous invite à voter cet
amendement merci Madame la rapporteur
bien je vais donc mettre au voix cet
amendement 303 qui vous l'avez entendu a
reçu un avis de sagesse du gouvernement
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté et
il fait tomber l'ensemble des
amendements qui suivent nous allons
continuer avec l'amendement 303 présenté
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales pardon 304 excusez-moi euh
c'est un amendement de coordination
madame la
rapporteur c'est je le je le lis tout
simplement c'est un amendement la l'avis
de du gouvernement favorable qui est
pour cet amendement de là qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement 304 est
adopté nous passons à l'amendement 1189
présenté par Madame Ferré je vous en
prie merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre donc par cet amendement nous
proposons que soit remis au Parlement un
rapport qui analyse les conditions d'une
convergence tarifaire entre pour chaque
section et pour l'ensemble des sections
et portant une attention tout à fait
particulière sur la section
hébergement merci beaucoup l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement vous
connaissez la position constante de la
Commission et c'est donc un avis
défavorable avis du
gouvernement la position du gouvernement
elle est aussi constante madame la
rapporteur avis défavorable merci Madame
la Ministre deux avis défavorables sur
cet amendement 1189 qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous continuons avec l'amendement
1191 présenté par Madame Ferré merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
c'est à nouveau la proposition donc d'un
rapport je sais que par principe c'est
tout à fait gênant quand même que par
principe et la Commission et vous madame
la ministre vous soyez opposé à un
rapport en tout cas un autre amendement
donc propose ce rapport qui permettra de
clarifier la section devant financer
chaque type de dépense en
épad merci beaucoup l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement pour les
mêmes raisons avis défavorable l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cet amendement
défavorables deux avis défavorables sur
l'amendement présenté par Madame Ferré
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je passe
au voix l'article 37 qui qui est pour
l'article 37 qui est contre qui
s'abstient l'article 37 est adopté nous
continuons avec trois amendements
identiques j'ai le 139 rectifiire
présenté par Monsieur
Milon merci madame la Présidente
l'amendement proposé donc poursuit la
volonté de simplification et de